twin motion or endcap today we finally
settled the argument 2024 brings us some
incredible updates for both platforms
and Mac is finally catching up to
Windows when it comes to rendering So
today we're going to explore twin motion
and nscap put them to the test head-to
head and see which one produces the best
renders are we ready let's go so now we
have twin motion open on the one side
and
endscreen directly out of Arad so we
have Arad open as well with the actual
credit scene of this kitchen now we're
going to start with andscape because
andscape logs directly into Arad and you
kind of have to have the split screen
view on andscape we have created our
kitchen render we have used nothing but
the materials available to us in our
material editor on aryad itself from the
andscape library so with their latest
update their material Library comes with
a ton of amazing things there's only
three materials that I've changed in
this scene the wood floor which is now
wood 10 strip the island bench itself
which is marel 05 and the backdrop
Cabinetry is wood
27 so the three main items in this scene
everything else is white Plaster board
nothing special and I've also introduced
two chairs from the
like this there really isn't too many
settings that we've changed in the main
image quality we've just bumped it up to
ultra we've adjusted some of the
highlights and the Shadows mainly just
to bring up some of those black
undertones in this capet the atmosphere
haven't really touched it at all the sky
we've left as the default generic sky in
ncape we haven't even added a hdri and
of course output 2,000 by 22,000 which
is perfect for social media we're
exporting as a PNG
to be able to get best quality out of
this and we're not really doing anything
else to be able to get something like
this from aryad into endcap takes less
than 30 seconds of work it really is not
hard to get high quality images now if
we were to export this image turn our
safe frames on to see exactly what we're
getting hit the export button and start
the
timer and there we go our final andscape
exported image let's put them side by
side so we can compare on the left we
have our exported image which is crisp
clean and actually phenomenal for about
30 to 45 seconds worth of work on the
right hand side we have that live
version while this is running on a Mac
Studio M1 Ultra for comparison's sake so
that took 30 seconds did a phenomenal
job for me personally andscape to be
able to get results like this in easily
under 5 minutes of actual working time
is a great starting point now let's move
on to twing motion if you're enjoying
the content so far thank you so much for
watching if you're new here my name is
David tomich I'm a registered architect
here in Western Australia and we're
doing our absolute best to grow this
channel as far as we possibly can this
year right now it stands at about 47,000
subscribers that's
47,000 amazing people who have smashed
that subscribe button down below for
2024 I'd love to see it grow to over
100,000 now that's a ridiculously
optimistic goal but one I think that
together we can reach so please hit that
subscribe button share it with your
friends and let's reach that goal
together so of course the nscap image
still on one side twin motion on the
other they're both generically looking
quite similar at this stage inside the
program personally inside the program I
think twin motion still has it beat but
we'll see what happens when we export to
be able to get twin motion to do this
quality of export there's a couple
things you need to change first of all
multi GPU path tracing is activated how
much that changes at the current point
in time I think very little but I've
turned it on just in case Skydome
resolution I've kept that on high for
export grass fading I've kept it on far
and otherwise everything else is set to
ultra on the computer so you can see the
best quality from a settings perspective
the environment's changed the global
lighting has changed the exposure
changed almost everything has changed to
match what endcap is able to bring in by
default so I did have to spend a couple
minutes adjusting the Skydome changing
the rotation intensity messing with the
actual ambient lighting the white
balance just to kind of get it close the
camera has been set to 31 mm which is
the equivalent of nscap if we go in here
you'll see field of view is
60° which is approximately same as 31 mm
in a camera length so our exposures are
exactly the same viting I'll adjust to
zero just to get rid of some of that
vignetting you can actually see it on
andscape
but personally I don't like the vetting
so I've just dropped that off power
realism has been turned on render of
course Lumen settings activated and some
of the Shadows adjusted so we get some
nice Feathering and tapering like we
have over here on ncape effects nothing
much 55 contrast 45% saturation and our
image settings are exactly the same so
at this point in time I'm ready to hit
the export button once again set it to
PNG so we have the same file format
export and start this
timer and there we go we were able to
export twin motion's image significantly
faster compared to that of ncape so
verdict your twin motion export is going
to take less time to export however it
will take more time to create looking at
these images side by side personally I
think they look great endcap on the one
side for the amount of effort we put
into this render I think that looks
really really good on the other hand the
twin motion render actually has a little
bit more life a little bit more depth a
little bit more character it looks like
it could be a real photo however I'm
sure if I was to spend a little bit more
time in endcap and compare that equally
with a little bit more time in Twin
motion we might be able to bring these
renders out to a much higher standard
let me know down below what you guys
think